each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a great pleasure to introduce
Harry Jew from Ohio State University
Harry is a PhD student and he's going to
graduate this year so he's here to talk
about his PhD work Harry had some great
internships at IBM research and some of
the two internships sort of prompted his
line of thinking around understanding
how programs use memory and the aspect
of memory bloat which he's actually
investigated over the past few years
with a number of really interesting
publications Harry's received several
awards including an IBM research
fellowship a fellowship at the area of a
distinguished paper award XE and also a
departmental of fellowship at Ohio State
University so without L injured is Harry
thank you for him thank you thank you
ban for introduction so it's a great
pleasure here to talk about my research
so okay so let's get started maybe um so
I'm actually a program not the person
I'm interested in both theoretical
foundations program analysis and this
applications so important applications
that forms the basis of my PhD thesis is
to use static and dynamic program notes
techniques to help programmers find and
remove what we call runtime bloat in
modern object or any software so this
research here is motivated entirely by
the real world problems that we have
regularly encounter in the study so here
I'm tell the story all right so else
probably all of us here have releasing
the past decade has witnessed a
tremendous increase in the size of
software which now contains more and
more functionality and consume the more
and more resources in order to solve
increasingly important problems so this
picture shows the the growth of the
total number of objects in the heap in
the large Java server application over
the course of two years between 2002 and
2004 so the total number objects in the
heap has increased for example from less
than half a million in the beginning all
the way up to 30 millions then like more
than 60 times over this two-year period
so what happened to this application why
does this application
consumed so much memory now because now
we have this big pileup thing so this
picture shows the architecture of the
SLP the sap netweaver application server
where it's box in this picture represent
a component of the server so this
application server has millions lines of
code and needs about 20 components to
work simultaneously in order function so
one important thing that can be seen
from this picture is that this
application server itself is Bill is a
big pile up right it's built on top of
layers layers frameworks and libraries
so first of all it can be extremely easy
for such a large-scale framework
intensive application to suffer from
performance problems so for example
suppose they exist small performance
issue in one of the components here its
effect and quickly get orders magnitude
more significant ones those components
become nested and layers right and
second if this application has a small
performance problem it will be extremely
hard for their developers to find why
because the problem can easily across
many many layers of libraries and
frameworks and those libraries and
frameworks can come from different
vendors in most cases their source code
is not available so as a result
significant performance degradation and
scalability problems can be regularly
seen in large scale and real-world
applications all right so a lot of
evidence has been shown that you know
most performance problems in modern
object-oriented software are caused not
by the lack of hardware support but
instead by runtime redundancies or in
efficiencies during the execution so we
call this general redundancies or in
efficiencies runtime blowed a typical
example of bloat is to use a very
complex have a will function to achieve
very simple task which should have been
shipped in a much easier way below has
caused you know applications to consume
increasingly large memory space so for
example a typical java application java
heap has quickly grown from you know for
example 500 megabytes a few years ago to
2 to 3 gigabytes today it's very common
but
doesn't necessarily means that we're now
supporting more users or functions right
so here's the list of a common bloat
effects that we found in real world
applications that we have studied so for
example a large-scale application
originally designed to support millions
of concurrent users can eventually scale
only two thousand users in practice and
it was extremely hard for their
developers to find out the reason so
they gave it to IBM Research for
performance tuning as another example
the designer of a large-scale
application initially expected only two
kilobytes memory for saving session
state per user but eventually they found
500k you know for saving you know
sessions per user more than 250 times
larger than they initially expected so
the consequence upload is not just
excessive memory usage large memory
consumption usually comes with the
execution of a lot of redundant
operations that can cause a significant
slowdown of the application so blue cap
can have huge impact on scalability
power usage and performance of
large-scale real-world applications that
form the backbone of modern enterprise
computing used every day by thousand
businesses below can also have a huge
impact on mobile computing where most
applications have very restrict resource
constraints according to IBM research
millions of dollars are spent every year
by this customer on memory like blue
detection like performance tuning and
memory leak detection so that's why IBM
research is pushing very hard to develop
useful tools that can help programmers
identify performance problems alright so
what can we do what can we do to deal
with this ever-increasing level of
interest efficiencies the first thing
that we can probably think of
immediately is to use compiler
optimizations but programmers people's
general you know feeling is like this we
don't need to worry about performance in
object orientation because we have this
advanced compiler technology we have
this a garbage collector right so let's
live it entirely to the compilers and
the wrong time systems because they are
always smarter than ourselves that's
basically what people think in the real
world however
the usefulness of this compiler
traditional compiler technology is very
limited in optimizing blow away because
a general data flow in large-scale
application can easily across south and
massive occasions many many layers of
libraries and the even frameworks this
is a very large scope way beyond the
world competitor analysis would inspect
and of course optimizing a lot of
real-world problems may require a lot of
developing side which is a compiler
doesn't have on the other hand is not
easy as well for the human experts to
perform any optimizations primarily
because of the lack of good tools that
can help them make sense of large heaps
with millions of objects and long
executions that can last for hours and
days so my entire sisters here is to
find a better way that can identify
larger optimization opportunities with a
small amount of developer time how can
do that the basic methodology is 2l
elephas compiler assistive manual tuning
in order to really take advantage of
both sides the menu options in sight and
the compiler side specifically of design
implemented and evaluated static and
dynamic program noses techniques that
can first identify the root cause of a
memory problem or performance problem
and second remove automatically or
manually some kinds of blow patterns
that we you know identified with these
techniques and third preventable from
occurring in the early stage of software
development this is the extra three-step
approach all right so our techniques
were implementing honorable a variety of
different platforms so for example the
dynamic analysis were implemented on you
know GM IBM gni which is the commercial
JVM of IBM Jack's rvm which is open
source JVM reading Java and also use GV
MTI which is a like general to interface
supported by audio VMS and the you know
the damning nozzles can be used to
general generate online blow warnings
during the execution of the program the
static analysis were implemented on suit
which is a popular program now so if we
move for java the static analysis can be
used either to produce online I mean not
online to produce blow warnings or to
generate refraction suggestions during
coding ones developers write our code so
this really demonstrates that our
techniques are generally enough as they
are now limited advice any specific
platform or framework alright so this
slide shows an overview of the set of
techniques that I have developed from
Isis's for example for dynamic noses we
start with profiling the execution to
identify certain load evidences like a
lot of copies large cost-benefit rituals
high memory leak confidences there are
all strong indicators of blood and then
by analyzing the profiled activities
will generate blood or memory leak
report for static analysis we analyze
the bytecode of large-scale applications
to identify third and blow patterns that
we have previously found using the
dynamic analysis in order to either
generate blow warnings or to transform
the program to produce optimized code so
for example static analysis can be used
to help programmers identified loaded
containers they can also be used to help
programmers fine and hoist loop
invariant deal structures so in a digit
in addition to software blot analysis
I've also contributed to some other
program announces areas so for example
very interested in scalable point
student data flow analysis I've done
some work on controlling data flow now
so for s back year which is you know the
major aspect oriented language I also
have some experiments with language
level or checkpointing and replaying in
terms of research areas my work goes
from very high level software
engineering across programming languages
compilers all the way down to run time
systems so this slide should gave the
detailed classification of the
publications in terms of research areas
so i actually have experience and
expertise in these three areas so now
we're done with the introduction part
now let's get little deeper into the
technical problems and solutions so here
i'll talk about two specific program
nozzle techniques to help programmers
find and remove
one dynamic analysis in the one static
analysis the goal of the dynamic
analysis is to find low utility dead
structures to help programmers to
performance tuning the stacking stacking
losses can be used to help programmers
fine and hoist loop invariant death
structures so the go I mean that the
motivation of the second static analysis
is based on a lot of looping variant
data structures that we found using the
first dynamic analysis that's how these
two analysis are connected so eventually
I'm going to talk about the future work
and conclusions alright so this is the
first piece of work which was published
in Peoria lost one of my PID I 2010
papers the goal of this analysis is to
identify high costs low benefit dead
structures that are likely to be
performance bottlenecks so how can do
that we design a runtime analysis that
computes a cost measurements and the
benefit of measurement for each data
structure in the heat and eventually we
present to the user a list of the data
structures that are ranked based it on
based on their cost benefit of rituals
intuitively data structures with a high
cost benefit of rituals are likely to be
closely related to performance problems
that's the motivation alright so before
getting deeper into the technical
problems and the solutions let's first
look at the go through this a motivation
part yeah sure another cost but back in
the cost of extra memory isn't I mean
they're sure to the subtle in direction
in the sense that the cost of extra
memory isn't visible unless you notice
performance effects from to say for
example you know it's bigger than the
cache etc oh yeah so how did you do you
get when you talk about cost you get to
the actual cost in terms of the impact
on cycles are you actually is it just
like a more memory is better no I mean
restore is so I think it's cause the
benefit is defined in terms of like the
actual computation down instead the
model memory needed you guys or
something so it's like the more about
execution bloat or instead of a memory
bloat okay so
okay so oh you go yeah yeah I hit you so
okay I mean this is actually this first
go through the motivation as we probably
know I already know wrong time below can
manifest itself through many observable
symptoms so for example a lot of
temporary objects that are really sure
lift objects right there now long lived
a lot of pure data copies without any
computation down and maybe you know a
lot of highly still objects many objects
without any I mean that are now used for
a long time and many problematic
containers may be many many other
symptoms that we're going to observe in
the future however in any tuning task it
will probably be impossible for
developer to try all those different
techniques all look at all those
different symptoms to identify
performance problem so that basically
doesn't make sense I merely a question
to ask here is that is there a common
way or in other words more systematic
way beyond all these different symptoms
and techniques that can characterize
different kinds of bloat even though
they could exhibit different symptoms as
below is really about wrong time in
efficiencies we found that what is
really common about different kinds of
blood is that there exist operations
that are very expensive very hard to
execute but do not produce data values
that have large benefit or impact on the
forward progress in other words the cost
of those operations are out of line with
their benefits this observation actually
motivates us of computing to compute
this a cost-benefit measurements to help
programs to a performance tuning so how
we do that let's first look at example
um this example shows here's a problem
that we found from a closed peripheral
framework using our dynamic analysis so
here's a method called its package that
takes a java string as input and
eventually returns whether or not this
dream represents a value java package
name right the way this method is
implemented that it first calls another
method
cause called directory lists in order to
identify and return a list of all files
in this current directory represented by
a skier and then it checks whether or
not this return list equals now because
now so it's easy to see that there's a
much easier way or smarter way to
implement this method right the for
example we can directly parse this
incoming string into two parts like Java
and I oh and check directly whether or
not they correspond to Valley the Java
directory names right that we don't
necessarily have to do you know find all
the files in the directory so in this
case for example this you know big
leaves date structure pointing to buy
this variable packs has the highest cost
benefit rituals because intuitively
there's a lot of effort made to identify
those files and you know populate this
entire list but eventually enough the
elements in the list are used for any
purpose so the cost-benefit ratio is the
highest so for this example I mean this
example actually shows a typical problem
with the current object or any
programming practice so for example the
programmers are encouraged to pay more
attention to high-level abstractions
like modularity reuse readability
without considering performance so for
example in this case think about why the
programmer wants to do this why the
program wants to implement this mess in
this way the only reason that I can see
here is that the programmer just wants
to reuse the implementation of this
method directory list instead of
creating a specialized simplified
version for it right however there never
wear that this piece of code can be
executed for millions of times and one
of this list becomes large it really
hurts performance in fact by simply
creating a specialized version for this
method we were able to reduce the
running time for this application by
eight percent which is very impressive
all right now let's go back to the
definition so what is called yeah sure
percent
easily apparent in a profiler is a
hidden bias much of it costs being
effects on garbage collections well um I
think I generally I think is always a
problem yeah but if someone decided I
care up forms this program i'm good
profile would they have been identified
problem by looking at the the simple
profiles and at least were they have
been told to look at this package or
would it have been spread out by mostly
secondary GC costs or something like
that well we don't have sort of a
detailed profiles up there you know like
like what percentage of that eight
percent comes from the GC and what
percentage come from if you just used a
very simple technique for just you know
file profiling the amount of time spent
in oh ok just directory this pop up well
I've no actually if you look at the
Jesus and the simple profiles after like
the running time profiles up to the
large-scale application like like
eclipse there's a I'll give you a very
specific example so if you look at the
large-scale applications like we have
profile we have did we have downloads
profiling for this large-scale
applications we found that so most
frequently executed the method for this
big application is a method called
hashmap yet so it it turns out that mean
the message like that can never be me
the most excavated method most
frequently executed method you had you
you're showing up is eight percent you
would have seen oh eight percent is for
this little tiny is packaged thing I'm
no I mean that the profile cannot say I
mean if you look at the Ronnie time
profiles it never shows like a percent
for this method right I don't because it
cost yeah you see costs associated yeah
there's a lot of different things going
yeah no there's no yeah so that's
probably the answer right okay yes yeah
yeah ok now let's go look go go back to
this cost benefit thing so so what is
costing what is benefit so the absolute
costs offer he brought you here is
defined as the total number of
instructions executed to produce a value
so each instruction here has the three
address representation like a equals B
equals B let's see and each instruction
here is considered to have unit cost
right so there's that part is it really
easy to understand and then so it's a
little tricky to define what the benefit
is as a benefit of a value is really
related to how good the consumption of
the batteries right so there's no clear
metric for for that so here we'll give
you some intuitive definitions of the
benefit a layer I'll talk more about the
form of definitions so intuitively a
benefit of a value is defined as a very
large number if this value this hip
value goes to program output like sake
or file system because you know is
actually used for any purpose for some
purpose of course its benefits 0 if this
value is hip Valley is never used you
know the circus here is the most common
case where this hip value is used to
produce another value not a hippo value
V Prime in this case the benefit of V is
defined as a module down to transform V
into V Prime so there's some kind of
relationship between the cost of your
prime and the benefit of V so again
these are just intuitive definitions
I'll give you more specific or formal
definitions later on during the talk so
first let's look at the cost computation
how can compute the cost a natural idea
to compute a cost for a program like
this will be to capture a dynamic
dependence graph you know it looks like
this one here right where each edge
represent the date dependses
relationship between a pair of
instructions while writing to a memory
location and the other reading from the
same location right so for example
suppose now we won't compute the cause
of adi here it can be computed if you
know efficiently by traversing backward
this dependence graph and counting the
total number of ritual knows what you
represent the snow total number of
instructions executed which is actually
for in this case so we caused this
problem a backward dynamic flow problem
because in order to solve the problem we
need to record and traverse backward
some kind of a history information of
the execution so this is the backward
flow problem as opposed to a forward
problem right there are actually many
many other backward dynamic flow
problems this is just one of them if
you're interesting those other problems
you can look at the paper or we can talk
offline so in general the only way to
solve this backward dynamic flow problem
is to use dynamic slicing that captures
a dynamic dependence graph that look
like this so for example I mean the Navy
the size is actually a general dynamic
technique that needs to record all
memory accesses and during the execution
and their dependents relationship right
so it's easy to see that dynamic slicing
is prohibitively expensive for
large-scale and long running
applications because the traces the
genre's the dynamic lighting generates
is unbounded it depends completely on
the dynamic behavior of the program so
it's pretty prohibitory expensive
however I mean so in order to efficiency
and the maker announced is more scalable
we propose a new technique here called
abstract dynamic slicing that performs
dynamic slicing over bonded abstract
domains so the motivation of this new
technique is as follows if we look at a
specific client OSIS that uses the
result of the slicing algorithm the tree
is generated by the name is slicing
generally provides many more details
than this you know this specific client
would possibly need so a natural
question to ask here is that
is it possible to let the slicing
algorithm be aware of this client houses
so that it can capture only part of the
execution that is relevant only to the
client in other words we wonder whether
or not is possible to customize the
client NASA the the slicing algorithm
with the semantics of this client houses
the answer is yes and we do this by
looking at abstractions so we found that
for many backward dynamic flow problems
equivalent classes exist so here is a
simple example that shows a fragment of
program trace that contains different in
runtime instances of the same
instruction k equals BLM each
instruction instance here is annotated
with an integer I that represents the
ice execution of that instruction so
given the client assets are specifically
analysis it would be possible for us to
divide those equivalent the runtime
instruction instances into two
equivalent classes like e 1 and E 2 so
later it would be sufficient for the
client houses to look only at those
equivalent classes e 1 is to instead of
looking at individual run home
instruction instance so in this way we
can potentially record only one runtime
instruction instance per equivalent
costs as its representative now that can
potentially lead to a group you know
significant reduction in the amount of
memory needed right it's easy to see
here that the dependence graph computed
this way is an abstract dependence graph
where each node represents an equipment
costs and each edge connects two
equivalent classes as long as there
exists the dependence relationship
between two runtime instruction
instances aggregated into the equivalent
classes right so we've actually
generalize this idea and define a more
generous erratic framework that can be
instantiated to solve many many other
backward dynamic flow problems this talk
focus only on high-level ideas if you're
interested yeah sure
well I mean that's the user has to
provide some kind of annotation like the
designer of the analysis gave the
semantics of analysis so that our
analysis are profiling from work takes
analysis that takes the semantics as
input and defines the secret in classes
yeah I'll give you specific now sure of
course so what's your question man no
today okay sure yeah yeah of course of
course um I mean here's example so so
let's look at the you know go back to
cost computation how we're going to use
apps within aiming slicing to compute
cost for for for a specific around home
value so recall that the absolute cost
for a random value is defined as the
total monthly instructions executed
right to produce the body so here for
example the absolute cost for specific
around humming structuring instance like
this 1a equals B plus C and 3120 can be
computed by traversing backward this
concrete dependence graph and counting
the total number reachable knows what
you represent and total nom for
instruction executed right right that's
basically for absolute cost for the
concrete dependence graph however as we
already know concrete dependence graph
is very expensive to compute in addition
it's very hard for the programmer to
make sense of a specific runtime
instruction instance because the static
instruction can potentially have
millions of runtime instances so it
doesn't make sense for the programmer to
so that the program makes sense with the
cost for a specific one to solve the
problem though instead of computing this
absolute cost for specific around honey
instruction instance we're proposed to
compute abstrac off for an equivalent
costs of instances so for example the
abstract abstract cost for an equivalent
cost like like this 1a equals B plus C
with them with annotated with zero can
be computed by traversing backward this
abstract dependence graph and
calculating the sum of the sizes of the
rich Bo equivalent classes right the
size of the equivalent cost is
essentially the total number of
instruction instances aggregated in the
eye cream class
so in this way we can usually find that
in the first of all abstract dependence
graph is much easier to compute and
second is easier for the programmer to
make sense of it because the apps your
cost for an equivalent cost is
essentially the app flew costs for set
of runtime instruction instances
aggregated based on some kind of
obstructions right now the question is
what is the profit abstraction that we
can use for computing costs here that's
basically you guys question right so all
right so here we use calling context to
define equivalent classes in other words
those a 10 to be 47 is 0 our object
sensitivity based calling context
specifically each of the e here is the
chain of receiver object allocation size
for the call sites on the call stack in
this way will be natural for us to
aggregate runtime instruction instances
based on object our needle structures so
if you're interesting object sensitivity
we can definitely talk offline that's
basically the general idea ok yep so the
instruction personal blue you carry only
once for that coin context
million times right right Luke I mean we
only consider the master calls like the
chain of the mass of the object the cost
still be very skewed or away from the
ABS action oh yeah there's still like
different yeah sure yeah it is not very
accurate I mean it's like a proclamation
yeah it could be over personated I think
there's always over peroxidation you
know I just gave in example it's not
their approximate right you can tell me
if it's an instruction inside a loop you
will carry only once based on the coin
context even though I executed a million
times they go around a loop a million
times you go wrong loop million times
with every I mean we the cost is
actually the frequency right it's
considered the frequency of that house
you will count the number of and eggs
Dietrich ears he wants to limit the
number of the size of that I am I
understand yes that right so he's going
to have you're iterating a million times
over like a million objects okay but the
call stack remains the same so you're
you're not that you couldn't hustle so
you're not retreat okay so you have 1
equals class and then you have a count
Yeah Yeah right right sure so yeah it's
considered frequency action so sorry
static analysis case you use some
estimate adventure movies or something
to
first is the naming no it's not that you
know you're trying to decide later
children statically uh that's little I
don't know there's not quite
straightforward for me I don't take this
information combining to stay that you
can try to do it no this is completely
random noises all right so so far all
costs that we have talked about our
cumulative cost that measure the effort
made from the very beginning of the
execution to produce a run home value so
however we found that cumulative cost is
not quite useful in helping programmers
understand performance problems because
it's almost certain that value produced
later during the execution has a higher
cost then the value produced early
during the execution right there does
exist a strong correlation between a
high cost and a performance problem so
in order to solve the problem we propose
to compute relative cost instead of you
know cumulative cost so the relative
cost for a run time value like a hip
location hip value is defined as the
multiple down on the stack that
transforms values read from other
existing hip locations in order to
produce this value I shows by example
let's consider this picture where boxes
represent objects address represented
flow so fghj represent obvious fields
suppose now we won't compute the cost
403 if one computer is cumulative cost
we only need to consider so we basically
need to consider this month were down
and pretty much all the work down from
the beginning in order producer values
written those in 203 right all the work
however if one computed the relative
cost we're only to consider this
mountain work done on the stack that's
transform values read from other
existing hip locations like 01 02 in
order to produce the values in 203 so
this is actually the fundamental
difference between relative costs and
cumulative cost completely symmetric to
relative occult relative benefit for hip
value is defined as the model work down
on a stack that transform this value in
order to produce values written into
other hip locations
consider again this example so for
example now we won compute benefit
relative benefits 403 we're only in to
consider this month walk down on stack
that's transform 03 into other hip
location like 04 and 05 so it's clear to
see that relative benefit for hip
location is determined by both the
frequency and the complexity of the use
of that value right so eventually you
know the costs and benefits computed
fight in the four individual hip
locations are aggregated based on object
structures in order to produce costs and
benefits for high-level dead structures
so this last reveals some of the key
problems and challenges ideas in this
work so for example solve the first
problem then a mcfly singh is too
expensive we propose to use a new
technique cut a pure dynamic slicing
that performs the naming slicing over
bounded absolute domains to solve the
second problem which is how to abstract
instances 400 data structures we're
proposed to use object sensitivity based
the calling context as obstruction to
solve the third problem which is
cumulative cost is not correlated with
the performance problem we proposed to
use relative cost instead of cumulative
cost so combining all the three insights
we eventually compute relative abstract
cost and a relative abstract benefit and
use this cost-benefit ratio as an
indicator to performance problem so this
analysis was implemented in IBM gni
virtual machine and we performed case
studies on the real world large-scale
applications so in fact all those are
you know applications here except blowed
have millions lines of code this picture
shows the running time reductions that
we have achieved after removing the
problem that we found using this dynamic
analysis cost-benefit analysis so for
example for bloat there are thirty-five
percent of running time reduction that
we have chief after removing the
problems this is actually the very first
dynamic analysis targeting general bloat
all existing work target different kind
of
symptoms like symptom-based upload this
is actually the only way the only piece
of a word that targets the blend thank
you Kevin sure bring it a little example
with the package Oh explain our
relations analysis so how we did it yeah
how do you compute the relative cost
yeah sorry I'm sorry all the way back
again sir so yep what ends up being the
relative cost of whatever act and
knowledge and well so so first of all
consider the relevant fit the ballot is
really easy to compute this case because
knobs elements in the hip locations the
hip values in this list are used for any
papers right so they're never used
because don't you only use this
reference value you never retrieve the
human levels from this list right so the
benefit for this entire list is 0
Yankees 0 well I mean 0 service I mean
it's yeah we do the data for groups here
for did the membership like that's equal
whatever it does have equal mean this is
a reference I mean this is a pointer
value is this is not like the heap the
value retrieved from the hip location
right so there is a large banners their
large cost associated with list because
you know you have you compute all those
files you populate the list so every
data member in the list has a large cost
associated with it right because you do
a lot of computations in order produce
values and I write them into that hip
location the list location right is this
why there's you know it's clear to see
that there's very large cost but there's
no benefit I mean very little benefit so
you get a large yeah those or its sound
benefit is you have to test against
strength is it a package deal yeah we
should is a test
in the result they match yeah sure sure
yeah yeah we can definitely talk offline
I mean some subtle she was here let's go
all the way forward um all right so um
yeah sure into the blow blow is it
constructed example or is it is that I
know that yeah what blood is a program
now the framework her written by a
Purdue University like a many years ago
a few is a large Java program now this
framework why is it blue I don't know it
was name of the application it wasn't it
was it was included in the de Cobo
benchmark sale yeah I years ago says s
basically well yeah okay what the reason
I mean why we can find this you know
such a large running time reduction is
because blood is pretty much written by
graduate students so the quality of the
code is really amines really poor their
mark Beatrice yeah yeah there's no no
okay I can't give you a specific example
later I'll fine yep all right so this is
actually the very first dynamic analysis
targeting general flow general bloat and
in addition is this work we have
identified a lot of interesting blow
patterns that can be regularly officer
observed in during the execution of
large-scale applications so you mean a
further step would naturally be to
develop a static analysis that can
identify and remove such patterns in the
source code so that the programmers can
avoid such small performance problems
during development during coding right
in order before those problems really
pile up and become significant so in
fact some of the interesting blow
patterns that we found in this work have
already led to the development of new
analysis and the tools so for example
give you specific examples we found a
lot of interesting like you know
container efficiencies so we develop a
new static analysis that uses contact
free language ability for Malaysian to
help programmers identity
I underutilized containers and
overpopulated containers that his work
was probably in another period 2010
paper and we found there a lot of
looping variant data structures in this
work so we used a type and effect system
to help programmers identify and hoist
the loop invariant dead structures some
other patterns that we found in this
work include problematic implementations
of a certain design patterns and
anonymous classes so actually the kind
of work that can do immediately will be
to develop static analysis to deal with
those patterns like three months work
all right so now we're getting to the
third part of the talk which is actually
the static analysis that can be used to
help programmers identify and hoist
looking variant data structures the
motivation of this particular analysis
is based on the observation that in
large-scale applications there are a lot
of places where objects with the same
content in the loop get created in many
many times by different loop iterations
and all their instances are exactly the
same it really hurts performance in many
cases so by pulling those objects autumn
loops in other words hoisting these
objects in a semantics preserving way we
can potentially save a lot of
computation as well as garbage
collection effort right so that's
basically the motivation let's first
look at example alright so this piece of
code show the problem in multiple
applications not only one applications
like multiple applications that we
studied in IBM teacher wasn't research
center so the loop here either is over a
string array cup date Dave here is a
string array in order parts each of the
stream in this array into a date object
right so this the way this met this loop
is implemented is that it creates a
simple data format object per iteration
of the loop and use this object to parse
you know issue of the strings so it's
easy to see that you know this entire
data structure reachable from this oh
SDF
which represents the cell here inside
gets created many many many times right
by loop iterations you know so and all
their instances are exactly the same in
many cases creating an object using this
new keyword in Java is much more than
allocating the space for the object it
can involve a lot of heavy with
operations to initialize a big deal
structure like this one here and create
a lot of other objects like this o1 and
o2 right so specifically for this case
creating one simple data format object
requires to load many resource bundles
from disk which can involve a lot of
very slow disk i/o operations so it's
very so it's perfectly okay for us to
put this out of loop and use only one
simple data format object 10 structure
to parse all incoming strings right yeah
sure yeah yeah sure said is perfectly
okay water stuff oh yeah sure yeah well
of course we have yeah I definitely go
to maybe there's five or six different
checks Oh like the very specific checks
over there so it's not that simple not
as employer that what I said in this
particular case it's the it's the case
that parse trees SDF doesn't read on the
object is other other mutating no
operations know our starting now our
static mouths can make sure that is that
snow on the class on the entire class is
there anybody you Tate a simple date
on the entire class what was your
property or simpledateformat stage once
instructed during you yes it is the
immutable right I think so yeah first I
mean you oh no no I think that the only
thing that is not immutable is you have
to load sort of the current data from
like a date and the whatever the date
and the time format from the local
computer to initialize this big there's
a lot of resources on is loaded yeah
what is constructed is memorable of
course so could this be solved at
library level by having like a stag
factory method that he'll did any
singleton object that was already oh of
course you can't you can definitely do
that yeah there's a possible way of
doing that right yeah that's definitely
one possible way of doing this
optimizing this case so is it often
oh well okay yeah but sometimes before
library designers they're not careful
enough to consider this kind of complex
cases or so so it's clear to see that
the challenge is the biggest challenge
in our work here is that we won hoist a
big dead structure out of the loop
instead of one single instruction or one
single objects that is the fundamental
difference between our work here and the
traditional compiler loop optimization
work so given the difficulty of a
hoisting a big dead structure of the
loop would divide this technical problem
into two sub problems one focus on the
data side one focus on the cosine so the
first sub problem here focuses on horse
body structure so which means that first
of all for each object created in the
loop we need to identify this entire
debt structure big deal structure that
is reachable from this object and then
we check whether or not all fields in
this big date structure or loop
invariant without considering any actual
code statements that access this data
structure so if all fields in this state
structure are looping variant we call
the state structure ahoy spoke this
structure back to the example our static
noises can make sure that this entire
deck structure reachable from OS DF is a
horse for data structure because no
field in any instance of the state
structure can contain iteration specific
value that can change across situations
our state analysis can make sure that
the help and once we have a set of high
school districts identified the second
step here tries to hoist the actual
condiments that access those thin
structures so the key idea here is that
for each horse building structure we
check each call sign that is invoked in
this on this date structure and see if
the hoist bow if this data structures it
I mean zips cos I is it indeed hoist
Bowl which is pull it up let's go back
to this example once we make sure that
this entire data structure rich bow from
OS DF is horse build a structure we
check each call site that is invoked on
object in this state structure so for
example we're first check this
allocation side because that lacanian
site is also call site right is a
constructor call and in this case the
application site itself is completely
hoist bowl so we're just put it out the
loop like this and then we check the
second call which is the call to master
parse however the second call here is
not forceful because the argument Dave
here contains iterations the Civic value
right they can crawl they can change
across situations our static analysis
can identify that so there's no way to
hoist the second statement I mean the
call site so this is actually what the
code looks like eventually after our
nozzle performs hoisting so it's
important to know that you know this
analysis is an interpreter to do compare
analysis it's not the source to source
translation or any some form of a
refactoring so this is a compiler
completely a compiler analysis all right
so let's first look at this first you
know technical problem sub problem which
is to identify which is focus which
focuses on the data side which is how to
identify horse body structures so we
found there are three challenges to
identify horse with the instruction so
the first challenge a here is to
understand how a deal structure is built
up so for example for each object
creating the loop we need to identify
what other objects are reachable from
this object this requires us to
reasonable points relationship right
it's very simple straightforward the
second challenge here is to understand
where the data comes from so for example
we have to make sure that no field in
the hoist bowdoin structure can contain
iteration specifically that can change
across situations that requires us to
reasonable dependence relationships and
the third challenge here is to
understand in which iterations the
objects are created so for example a
data structure at hoist Putin structure
can now contain objects that can be
created in different iterations
otherwise there is no way to hoist it to
understand this information we proposed
to compute iteration count abstraction
for each el cajon site
that can have three abstract values 0 1
and the bottom 0 here means that this
allocation site must be outside the loop
in other words all instances creating
the biases allocation site must exist
before the loop starts the second case
here is if the ICA for an alchemy site
is one is guarantee that this allocation
side is inside loop and no instance the
lifetime for any instance of the
allocation side must be within the
iteration where this instance gets
created in other words no instance of
the allocation side can escape situation
where is created two later iterations
and the third case here is bottom which
means that you know some is if the lq
side must be inside loop and some
instance of this LG incite my escape
situation where is created two later
iterations and may actually be used by
those later iterations so it's clear to
see that we're interested only in dead
structures where the icas for all their
objects are one right because it's
guarantees that you know all objects in
any instance of the ten structure must
be created in one single iteration and
all die as the end of iteration so the
IaaS for objects are computed can be
computed by general technical abstract
interpretation so this talk focused only
on how those high level analysis ideas
if you're interested in the slow level
analysis details we can definitely talk
offline or you can read the paper
therefore page formula and proof out
there all right sure you gave a
motivating ish
create an object that was immutable and
also presumably be the constructor
depended functional lady on in red on
things that weren't modified in the loop
correct but you have a much more
ambitious analysis here that's trying to
identify that that would handle objects
that are mutable but not mutated within
the loop is available but not mutated in
the loop you decide the funding the
concept of loop invariant and yeah
there's nothing that requires the the
objects to be deeply we ensure music I
mean we have this dependence analysis to
identify this kind of immutable fields
so it's immutable but not mutated in the
loop right you take it again it's not
mutated so you you can have a less
ambitious analysis that we'd identified
just completely immutable after
construction objects clatter be on a
class basis right ankle and it wouldn't
matter what happened mm-hmm oh yeah sure
I I definitely understand it our noses
are more ambitious in terms of your like
i identify you find actual cases in
which the the class is immutable bodies
is immutable but it's not mutated in the
room where you get extra benefit over or
just the point in you oh yeah sure sure
yeah yeah of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so how doesn't identify this
does hoist podia structures which
combined i means the interesting idea
here is do we combine the three
obstructions in and powerful way by
annotating points to and dependence
relationships with icas so here's an
example i don't don't know i have time
to talk about this but so how much time
do we have been okay so yeah okay i'll
continue so so let's first look at an
example so this the very simple example
that contains one loop and the four
objects so that let's first look as I
say for you shop tip here so the I say
for example for oh why here is 0 because
the allocation side is outside loop
right
easy I see a 402 is one because no
instance of this allocation side can
skip situation where it's created two
later iterations right this is the same
case 403 but 40 for the ica is bottom
because some instance of this allocation
side my escape situation right the
current situation where is created to
later iterations and may actually be
used in those later ations later
iterations you know for example here
listen so so basically 100 bottom are
the ICS for this for allocation size
it's pretty easy to understand this
picture shows the annotated points to
graph where each note represent an LG
incite an object H edge represent an
annotated points relationship which
contains a field name which fgh our
field and a pair of ICS for the two
notes two objects connected by the edge
so by reasoning about this points
relationship like this up annotating
points12 we can easily conclude that
this the entire data structure reachable
from 0 to it's not high school because
you know the ICF 404 here is bottom
because there's so there's no there's
you know there doesn't exist any way to
hoist the this this is the entire debt
structure this picture here shows the
end head of the dependence relationship
where it snowed represent either a hip
location or a stack location and if you
add to represent a dependence
relationship annotated with a pair of
ICS for the 2 News connected by the edge
the ICA for hip location like 03 total
value is actually the ICA for the object
Oh 3 which is one in this case the ica
for a stack variable is actually
determined by where the stack variable
is declared the very if the variable is
declared outside loop is I say a is 0 if
the variable is declared inside loop the
ICA is one so the I say for stack
variable can never be bottom because in
Java any variable declared in the loop
must be initialized every time the loop
interest right so you know for example
from from this case we can usually see
that this location OS retail value
depends on a stack variable
that can depend on self which indicates
that this hip location can contain
iteration specific value that can change
across situations so any data structure
that contains this location it's not
horrible so basically we found there are
four interesting properties in a hoist
bottom structure missing any of the
properties here can make a deal
structure not high school so first this
for interesting properties are disjoint
is confinement no I'm skipping a looping
very end so i don't think i would have
time to go through all the details i'm
going to probably skip those details so
if you're interested we can definitely
talk offline so there's one important
thing I can definitely report here that
is the verification of those four
important properties can be easily done
by performing checks on the annotated
points too and the dependence graph
that's the only thing that you need to
know to understand this piece of work
okay alright so once we have a set of
high-speed data structures identified um
it's really easy for us to identify
hoist pol calls you know the distro the
actual code statements that access to
the structure this is actually the
second step right I mean the most
important part of this work is the first
step as long as you understand the first
part it's really easy to understand the
second part so the key idea again is 24
issue each hoist bowdoin structure
identify it we check each call site that
is invoked on the deck structure and see
if it's a hoist boat this process can
involve you know like one two three four
five six six different checks can truly
balanced checks argument checks external
environment checks seven strong stress
control flow checks as long as all those
checks are satisfied this particular
call side can be hoisted so I'm not
going to talk about all those details as
they're very specific checks then I
declare their defines clearly in the
paper so we can definitely talk offline
if you're interested so that's pretty
much about this automatic work the sound
and automatic transformation however we
found that this completely sound and
automatically transformation is now
for effective in hosting real world and
structures there are basically two
reasons here first of all the real world
usage of java data structure is very
complex and annie's diagnose it has to
be over conservative to achieve 50 right
and the second reason here is that
hoisting a lot of real-world deal
structures requires developer insight so
for example consider a dense structure
where the 100 fuse if there's only one
field that is not looking variant this
can make this entire data structure now
Housefull however if this information is
given to the developer the developer
might have a way of hoisting the
structure for example the district the
developer might be able to split the
data structure into a horrible part and
now hoist apart right and pull out only
the hoist ball part so in order to make
our analysis more practical and help
programmers perform this kind of manual
hosting we're proposed to compute horse
ability measurements for each dead
structure in the loop that indicates how
likely this day structure can be
manually hoisted so for example we
consider metrics like dead horse ability
and code hoist ability I'm not going to
play all these details again they're
defined in the paper so we can
definitely talk offline so but there's
one important thing so which is the
computation of those heart's ability
measurements fits nicely very nicely
with the original analysis that we
proposed for transformation in other
words we don't need any new analysis to
compute those measurements they're
computed automatically ways the
transformation the actual transformation
so the analysis was implemented using
the suit 2.3 framework and evaluate it
on set of large 19 large java
applications is its 19 large job
applications a total 981 loop data
structures are considered in which we
found 155 date structures are completely
hoist building structures however our
completely sound and automatic
transformation was able to hoist only 14
structures in three programs completely
automatically because of the two reasons
that I mentioned so here's a list of the
district the running time reductions
that we have achieved after hoisting
those days structures completely
automatically
from those numbers we can easily see
that there's a large optimization
opportunity other but only small portion
of it has been captured by this
completely automatic transformation to
explore the rest we do menu hoisting
with the help of horse ability
measurements yeah yeah hoisting
something out of the loop in Java Sea no
oh yes yes so what was the data
structure they gave you that I don't
know actually this is a completely
automatic analysis and jealousy is now
open source so I saw you know I use a
nozzle to produce a new by collab new
version will by code and then I wrong
not run the new version and it causes
11-point percent running time reduction
I don't know what was actually going on
there so this is this is not open source
is this you know you can't get the the
the source code for this is this
application Java Sea application so um
but we do have open source I mean do
have sources source code for some other
applications so we study the five large
java applications by inspecting topped
and data structures ranked based on
hostility measurements we've actually
achieved much larger performs a
performance improvement then this
completely automatic shoes
transformation for example for
applications like PS which is the which
is the PostScript interpreter we're able
to make renounce make the application
wrong more than six times faster after
hoisting only a few data structures in
this core components and as another
example for applications like Zelan
which is the real world XML transformer
processor where there is a ten percent
of running time that reduction after we
hoisted only one xml transformer object
out of loop um so this sort of a
performance bug has been confirmed by
the de Cobo development team so there's
one I mean for this case we hoist it's
only one xml transform object so
p.s yes yes we founders the problem is
actually with with the the usage of the
data structure cut the stack the
programmer seem to understand I mean
they don't understand this step is a sub
cause the list so every operation they
they want to do with stack is they use
push in the pop so the keep pushing
popping stuff from the step they don't
understand the pop the the stack is a
sublet subclass of a list so they can
directly use something like gas to get
to retrieve a specific element that
means you know the use put beyond just
pulling it out of the loop or yeah
there's there's somebody something more
complex going on there so there's not
you know just hoisting the dead
structure but we found this problem by
identifying the hoist body structures so
we found there's no problems that we
found in this work have ever been
reported before in previous work so
alright so we're getting to the final
Park which is a future work and
conclusions of course are continue this
line of work on software blot analysis
because i think it's wide open area that
has so many interesting problems
challenges and potential research
opportunities we're actually very one of
the very few academic groups that are
doing fundamental research on this real
world problem why do I think it this is
a wide-open area because if you look a
little deeper into the cause of the
bloat you will see that the methodology
of object orientation itself encourages
certain level excess or bloat so for
example the programmers are encourages
to basically do whatever they want to do
to do favor reuse modularity readability
living performance entirely to the
compilers and the wrong hand systems
however if you want to advocate to
explicitly consider performance this can
have impact on almost the entire
software development cycle right so this
picture shows the kind of work that I'm
a planning and do in the future for
example we start with detecting
performance problems so once we find you
know the rule cost of those problems
we can either do menuing or we can
classify interesting blow patterns once
we have a set of interesting blow
patterns identified we can do a lot of
different things we can develop a static
a transformation that can automatically
remove such patterns in the source code
we can develop a self justing systems as
part of the feedback directed
compilation that can remove such
problems online at part of the JVM right
or like the se-r with the wrong time in
a Microsoft setting we can allocate
performance conscious software
engineering that can require a whole lot
of new things new design principles new
modeling tools new testing nozzle tools
new compiler spores and so on so forth
and we can also use the compiler to
synthesize a blow free implementation
given a set of performance
specifications so there are a lot of
interesting things we can do in the
future in addition I'm also considering
to leverage existing techniques from
other fields such as systems and
architecture in order to deal with this
ever increasing level of you know excess
or in efficiencies of course i'll also
look into other program analysis
actually we look into other program
announced areas so definitely one of the
things is to adapt existing techniques
to solve microsoft specific problems
like you know for the existing
techniques i are all the existing
techniques are implemented in within jvm
so is there so what is the what are the
problems that are specific to microsoft
products is there a possible way to
adapt those techniques into the crr you
know with zinc this microsoft family of
languages is that is that possible i
don't know so definitely is it's
interesting to see there are some other
interesting things that i'm planning to
do in the future like parallelism is
definitely one of most interesting
things still like optimizations database
the compilation model checking test in
debugging security privacy compilers for
hypothesis computing did locality i mean
the bottom line here is that I'm open
for collaboration with any researcher
who the research deals with the static
and dynamic program analysis that's
pretty much it my go so the conclusion
here
program now is the person I'm interested
in both in theoretical static and
dynamic analysis and both of the
principles and applications of the
program analysis my dissertation here
deals with the important application
which is software analysis that contains
both dynamic analysis that can help
programmers make more sense of heaps and
executions and static analysis that can
help programs remove and prevent blue so
with a set of techniques that I have
developed I hope that we can lower the
bar for performance tuning in other
words with automatically Automatica two
supports I hope that tuning is no longer
a daunting task I also hope to educate
the programmers developers in a real
world especially the OL programmers and
raise the awareness of this build
problems in the you know in a real world
of your learning programming so for
example the developers you really be
aware that performance is important they
should do everything possible during
development to avoid small performance
problems before they pile up and become
significant so this is because compilers
and Ron home systems are not always
smarter than human experts all right
thank you very much I'm ready to take
questions
a quick question for sure soon in all
the work that you talked about you
really need to talk it all about the
hardware or the cash sort of build a
hierarchy as a as a source of
performance complex are you is that
something that you intentionally didn't
investigate are you interested in SE and
how does it relate today well actually I
didn't I didn't get any chance we in
Vatican basket got me interested doing
that definitely so yeah I mean for
example the cost benefit thing is can be
deaf the current definition of
cost-benefit is defined in terms of
computation right the model worked on to
produce certain value it can naturally
be extended to work for like the cash
and other things I don't know how to do
that but i think is it's doable yes I
mean the answer to the questions that I
haven't done any work specific to the
cash in the memory hierarchy thing so
all the world's ever Dom are related to
program analysis that's a the only thing
that I have done
yeah for the first the first part yeah
the cost of entry so you gave a a
motivating example in which
there were a series of rights that were
never read mm-hmm and you had a
considerably more ambitious framework
for measuring the cost-benefit right did
you quantify and you can add a simpler
one that would just find identify rights
that were never read oh yeah sure and
I'm to quantify how much extra benefit
be oh yeah Extra Edition guess oh yeah
sure sure sure understand you're
probably a question well I mean we do
find sort of more complex cases where
the benefit part is not just like no use
so forgive very specific example we
found that for a lot of data structures
in large-scale applications they're just
purely copied from one source to the
other source like if you consider this
large-scale web-based applications they
have you know different components may
have different representation of the
same piece of data right so in order to
be transmitted the for example for j2ee
applications in order to be able to be
transmitted and network they have to be
wrapped into the soap sort of protocol
did so some piece of data keeps being
wrapping being wrapped and you know i'll
wrap in order to be transmitted between
you know different components so our
analysis can perfectly find places like
that so for example a piece of data is
you know is wrapped in this application
is this component but it's unwrapped is
that without any computation down so and
then there's definitely a lot of
optimization opportunities out there so
but we did find a lot of cases more
complex cases then the simply like no
use yeah yeah
right thank you thank you very much